well i share the horror of the world
following the invasion of ukraine and of
course it's created a humanitarian
catastrophe and we want to do all we can
to support ukrainians whether in ukraine
in neighboring countries or here in
britain in every way that we can this
morning a further flight left the uk for
ukraine via poland full of vital medical
supplies there's been three flights that
we've sent uh since
sunday and that's over 320 000 medical
items including you know medicines and
vital medical equipment wound packages
ppe
i i talked earlier this week with the
deputy health minister and we're clearly
working with with him in ukraine and his
department to make sure that they're
getting uh what they need uh at the same
time the uk government has increased
this overall or all humanitarian aid
package for by a further 80 million to
at least 220 million and of course we've
imposed some of the toughest sanctions i
think the toughest sanctions ever on a
g20 country working in concert with our
allies we will do everything we can to
support ukraine we stand with ukraine i
think we've done we've done a lot and
right after the the salisbury attack and
the the uk acted uh very decisively then
we've continued many of our sanctions
and of course because of the russian
invasion that we now see we've added to
that significantly working with our
allies as i say the toughest sanctions
any g20 country has seen we've also seen
this week the the home secretary has
announced uh further crackdown the work
through the national economic crime unit
something i did set up as home secretary
and i think that's really welcome as
well that we do everything we can
to to to
you to make sure that we're going after
anyone that's supporting uh putin's
regime but also at the same time keep
doing everything we can to provide that
vital humanitarian aid